let's see together what is the training
strategy of the word pieces algorithm
on how we perform the tokenization of
the text one strength
wordpieces is to colonization algorithm
introduced by google
it is used for example by birth
to our knowledge the code of work pieces
has not been open source
so we base our explanations on unknown
interpretation of the publish literature
so what is the training strategy of
workpieces
similarly to the bp algorithm wordpc
starts by establishing an initial
vocabulary composed of elementary units
and then increases this vocabulary to
the desired size
to build the initial vocabulary we
divide each word in the training corpus
into the sequence of letters that make
it up
as you can see there is a small
sceptility
we had two hashtags in front of the
letters that do not start world
by keeping only one occurrence per
elementary unit we now have our initial
vocabulary
we will list all the existing pairs in
our corpus
once we have this list we will calculate
a score for each of these pairs
as for the bp algorithm we will select
the pair with the highest score
taking for example the first pair
composed of the letters h and u
the score of a pair is simply equal to
the frequency of appearance of the pair
divided by the product of the frequency
of appearance of the first second by the
frequency of appearance of the second
token
thus
at a fixed frequency of appearance of
the pair
if the subparts of the fur are very
frequent in the corpus
then this score will be decreased
in our example the value appears four
times
the letter h four times on the layouter
the letter u four times
this gives us a curve of 0.25
note that we know how to calculate this
score we can do it for all pairs
we can know how do the vocabularies of
pair with the iscore
after merging it of course
on now we can apply this same fusion to
our split corpus
as you can imagine
we just have to repeat the same
operations until we have the vocabulary
of the desired size
let's look at a few more steps to see
the evolution of our vocabulary
and also the evolution of the length of
the splits
and now that we are up here with our
vocabulary you are probably wondering
how to use it to tokenize the text
let's say we want to tokenize the word
again phase
pieces follow these words
we will look for the longest possible
token at the beginning of the word
then we start again on the remaining
part of our word
and so on until we reach the end and
that's it again face is divided into
four subtokens
this video is about to end i hope it
helps you to understand better what is
behind the world what this is
you